rue de derrière la scène tantôt j'étais
très ému de voir l'hommage qu'on m'a
rendu l'espace et des photos des vidéos
dont 20 à 30 en pleine répétition de
votre nouveau spectacle humoristique
dans cadre du zoofest jeu c'est de
revoir ce que vous avez promis de tout
révéler sur votre carrière en toute
franchise x tra votre franchise
expliquez-moi comment vous étiez bec
jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans vous avez réussi
à vous transformer en l'homme que vous
êtes avec cette voix puissante avec un
drap viril - ben construction bug écoute
ses vingt cinq séquences heureux à
l'école de robecq genre de six ans et là
j'arrive pour avoir à écrire bien sûr et
là je prends mon crayon à la main gauche
erreur d'antan fallait pas faire ça du
tout du tout du tout
j'ai mangé des coups de règle mon ami
parce que la maîtrise de ses gardes et
non non xt dit non donc maintenant à toi
quand tu étais parti je voulais
apprendre que j'apprenais inscrits en
première année ça j'en ai plus long
message valeur amorcer ses méfaits comme
un un blocus c'est fou vers la maison
soi ou en classe quand on pose une
question en tête à queue bègles a
vraiment but là la personne doit arrêter
ça ça a été madame ou démente dans bien
des cours de diction et j'ai décidé
d'aller là j'avais 12-13 al amana modèle
m'ont arrêté le big m ² main promettait
des crayons quand de la bouche du bébé
et vous savez mon petit démosthène grand
orateur était bègue en moins et la
respiration pose de voix diction six
mois après off fini je ne bégaye est
plus en classe de seconde à gagner plus
non il n'ya pas si longtemps
étaient au même auteur et quand mais je
vais vous citer dans un publicité la
margarine la vie c'est une question de
choix et non de compromis la vie c'est
une question choix comment vous avez
fait ce virage mais le choix de de faire
beaucoup de publicité ça dans ma
carrière j'avais show du matin les
mennonites choses des choses du midi
l'après midi noda 20 le soir aux heures
et la tête chez vous
jamais ou arme je vois plus des enfants
quand même trop aux enfants un bon ange
jamais l'eau l'eau effectivement secours
du coup le cacheton comme on dit school
et les cachets à droite et à gauche
pourrait arriver à fait à faire quelque
chose parce que c'était peau topo ddd
sale affaire est muni des émissions de
tv old matin les besoins du matin là
c'est bon tu falloir faire pour moi
cette heure et trente et une tout de
suite nous allons retrouver claude
raymond enfin le suspense
sinon aussi ses tuyaux
moi je me suis dit peut-être naïvement
aussi me soutient si j'accepte de faire
de la publicité
ça vaut mieux garantir certains
paiements pour la maison pour tous le
voir je vais arriver dans nos affaires
et god
ça va me permettre de faire plus de
terres de faire autre chose même si vous
avez que loto québec
des fois je vais regretter souvent non
mes enfants me regarde aujourd'hui on
nous demande mais avec tout ça on se dit
ça c'est plus beau compliment que ça
avoir un moment donné parce que
disposant que j'avais fait beaucoup
pièce de théâtre qu'ils résident et
j'aurais réalisé des rêves g est un des
grands rôles j'aurais voulu faire mais
si tu richaud tu rates avis habré une
partie de ta vie ce sera ta vie de père
de famille
ça vous tue vraiment un vin et j'adore
mon métier
entendons-nous la danse mais aussi comme
aujourd'hui un âge canonique mais j'ai
encore un santé c'est le fun de jeudi
sans logis du tas est la question que
plusieurs se pose est-ce que c'était
payant très payant ou très très très
payant et je sais que l'argent c'est
tabou au québec faut pas en parler mais
là on n'aurait pas besoin d'en parler
ok je veux te réponds très très
clairement c'est très payant au québec
nom de domaine artistique c'est bon
c'est les commerciaux et puis via mais
c'est pas un million ses portes et je
peux aller chercher 50 5000 par année
mais ton c'est beau parce que ce soit
pour les commerces et publicité mais ça
dépend voilà bon si tu t'appelles
ingrate humoriste stenmark de gens qui
vont peut-être donné ça met du sien mais
bon moi j'ai jamais eue sur des ddd
cacher comme ça j'ai jamais eu sous mes
pourrait vendre la question une verge
c'est vrai qu'on en parle pour n'a pas
si souvent lorsqu'une peu l'impression
tiff par corbeil avec ses publicités
loto québec s'est rendu
multimillionnaire
non honnêtement je pourrais vivre mais
ton sans travailler mais pas en faisant
des folies ou non non non
corbet vous avez été très généreux avec
moi vous pensez y si le plaisir quand on
sait qui se sait spes d'humoristes de
relève qui est un art à eybens vieux du
lot 38 ans qui se rend compte que
personne jamais